catch the rest of you at the end but um
my name is erica smith i'm the deputy
director here at yei and just i'm really
thrilled to have
all of the tech boot campers the vcp
teams the summer fellowship and also the
other attendees that are interested in
learning more about what yei is doing
and also learning more about what mark
has to share
just to give you a brief snapshot of yei
the the programs that i described with
the summer fellowship we have some of
the top teams that have come out of our
programs throughout the year that are
growing and advancing their adventures
to try to basically take them and
commercialize their opportunities and so
forth to have nine teams being very
accurate programs we also have some rvcp
programs that
folks are working on that are basically
groups that have are launching their
product as well and are hopefully coming
and
advancing their ideas as part of the
programs that we develop here
in advance of consumers are working with
the summer fellowship team we also have
the tech boot campers which are spending
10 weeks doing nothing but programming
and learning how to
do
web development and we're thrilled to
have them here as well and i think that
all of the pieces um that are part of
the ydi programs between the
fellowship the vc summer vcp and also
our tech boot camp are really a part of
what mark has um pieces and has shared
in his history of launching ladders
also no sin as well and also as an alum
here from yale so i think with that i
will turn it over to him to describe
some of his background and how he kind
of took all these different components
from entrepreneurship to technology and
has created some very successful
businesses going forward
with that
thank you thank you
all right great well uh first off uh you
know you're all very strange you're
strangers most of all because your
team's playing in the world cup but all
of you are strange because you're
sitting here in a semi-hot you know
classroom to talk about entrepreneurship
and technology here on a gorgeous summer
day so uh congratulations so for being
so weird
all right uh so i'm mark cinedella uh
i'm uh yale class of 92 i was in td
yeah right i snuck in today and like the
butt the i snuck in there today and i
like the buttery is like completely like
different and upgraded and
compared to when i was here
and uh
uh it's that's it's amazing it's
fantastic um so here's what i thought
i'd do uh we got what 90 minutes ish so
uh when i uh i'll talk for like 45 and
uh i'll do like a third on how i got
from yale to kind of starting anything
uh a third on my first uh big hit
entrepreneur venture the ladders and
then kind of a third on
this next chapter and doing it again and
then we'd love to take your questions
and comments and uh
and feedback and uh and dirty looks from
people whose country is hosting the
world cup all right does that sound good
yeah that's not like a plan and if you
got a really really great and if you
have a really great question you can ask
it in the middle but only if it's like
really the best question that you've
ever thought of in like your entire life
so uh
uh so i was sitting i was just
mentioning i was sitting up like in that
third row from the back and fall of 91
in the american elections class i was a
policy
major and i didn't understand a dang
thing about business or
technology or anything when i graduated
here at yale yale doesn't have a
business major who doesn't do it at
least at that time didn't do a heck of a
lot about educating people about you
know how uh things work in the world
other than in the form of economics
and so i got to my senior year
i got to get a job what should i you
know what what should i do
and i'd work the reunions over uh over
the years and i found the reunions kind
of fascinating working with these people
who are kind of 20 or 25 years out
people are out as long as i've been out
now and i would observe them when i was
at the at the reunions and uh i noticed
something you know there'd be a lot of a
lot of folks
a lot of guys particularly who had kind
of been
uh here at yale and studied economics
and you know they'd talk about that i
went two years lehman and then two years
harvard business school and i've been 20
years at goldman sachs or morgan stanley
and now i'm a partner and you know kind
of uh
and like that's terrific and the world
needs partners at goldman sachs and
morgan stanley but for me i heard that
story and i just said you know that i
see a lot of my classmates kind of
heading towards that story
you know headed towards that that career
path
and i just don't i don't kind of want to
be like everybody else and that doesn't
that career path doesn't really
speak to me you know being a banker or
consultant or how many people how many
people your roommates
or yeah your roommates or your friends
are kind of thinking about going down
that path
yeah yeah everybody and how many and how
many of you
are like passionate about going down
that path like hey i want to do that
yeah all right good and that's eight
one in every room and uh and how many of
you have thought about it because you
don't really know how you're gonna pay
back your student loans otherwise
right a couple of hands up hands great
well this that's that first off that's
tremendous progress because 20 years ago
that was kind of the the the thing that
you would do you'd be headed out to
banking or consulting or maybe law
school or
uh working on a political campaign like
my roommates did
so uh but i saw that and said that's
just not my story that's not what i want
to be a part of it's not what i want to
uh want to do
i was reading the paper and i read that
international trade was going to be big
in the 90s and i said well i'm going to
go do international trade and uh being a
uh being before the internet and being a
data weenie i got the uh uh i got the
333 places rated almanac the 333 cities
in america raided one city per page and
i kind of did a little checklist and i
figured out what cities would i'd be
interested in moving to and i decided
between seattle and
san diego and if you heard earlier i'm
from buffalo and so uh i figured i've
done like kind of the northern city
close to canada thing with the crummy
weather why don't i try san diego uh
because it's close to mexico and it's
you know it's on a pacific ocean that's
got to be international right
so i moved out to san diego didn't know
anybody i worked in a couple other
companies for a few years and started a
company uh exporting
u.s made pet food to japan
and my notes say to pause for laughter
here so please go ahead
i'm laughing on the inside uh
and it's as strange as it sounds right
but i was uh uh it turns out that japan
imports a lot of agricultural products
and particularly pet food from the us
and so i was running up and down japan
selling you know pushing kibble and kobe
right and uh
uh you know
fascinating experience
um but after uh
you know after a couple years i realized
okay this is just me i've raised a
little bit of money to do this business
but like i can't raise any more money to
kind of get a bigger scale and uh there
was one morning i woke up at kind of a
you know in the hotel room in tokyo like
that scene in austin translation and uh
i said uh you know wow if i could be
like the king of the japanese pet food
business at the age of 30
would that be enough
and uh would that be like was that what
i want to do and i really decided no
that's not
it's not
it's not really
surprisingly enough that wasn't
fulfilling enough right uh
and uh so then i uh i figured hey won't
i uh want to go to uh i'll go to
business school right and i'll go to
business school give me a chance to
reset and i'll be able to kind of go do
something afterwards kind of on a bigger
scale
so i went to hbs and uh you know a lot
of great professors there one particular
uh professor said uh you know a couple
things that are interesting to me that
i always share with people in kind of
this this format because they're really
two of the greatest pieces of advice
that y'all that you'll ever get uh and
and one was look if you're thinking to
be an entrepreneur what a lot of you're
gonna say
he would tell the class what i'm gonna
say is uh i'm gonna go take the banking
job with a consulting job and make big
pile of money i'm gonna save a big pile
of money and then four or five years
from now i'm going to be able to go out
and start my own business
and this professor said well look i'm
going to give you some advice
all of you are going to ignore the
advice
and they're going to come back at the
fifth year union and say professor you
were really right about that advice so
the advice was
you know don't do that because
because two things one expenses rise to
meet income
so this this sounds kind of crazy to you
sitting here in in college or in grad
school thinking hey i really really know
how to manage a budget right now because
i don't spend much so why would i
possibly spend you know all if i was
making more why do i spend more
expenses rise to meet income you know
there's a
famous new york magazine article by tom
wolf on uh
living in new york called scraping by on
10 million dollars a year and it uh and
it goes through and it shows you that
when your peer group is spending this
there's social pressure there's
professional pressure there's personal
pressure uh there's psychological
pressure you just kind of end up
spending the same amount of money as
your as your peers you end up actually
not saving dough
you see and uh
and then the second thing is if you go
into banking or consulting one of these
things you're actually not going to
learn to do anything you're going to be
a highly paid
advisor with no experience to people who
are actually doing stuff
and that might seem interesting it might
seem great to be able to be the fly on
the wall and hear all this great stuff
but the really important thing about
being successful in business or
successful in your career isn't
sitting and listening to other people
making tough decisions
it's not
advising people what you would do if you
were in their shoes what it is is coming
at a decision that you've come to
through all the difficulties of making a
decision the pros and cons the sleepless
nights the tossing back and forth the
arguments sometimes the difficulty of
piecing out the signal from the noise
coming to decision and finally deciding
committing to your great decision and
like here's what we're going to go do
and then discovering that you're wrong
that's one of the most important things
that you can do in life
because you had all this particularly
group smart ivy leaguers like you
you have all these tremendous analytical
capabilities
that you have used over and over and
over in your life to kind of solve all
the problems that you've had in your
educational career
which is your profession right now but
that's how you've solved all your
problems
and discovering that sometimes that
doesn't work in the real world
is really one of the best lessons that
you can learn and then figuring out okay
well that didn't work what am i going to
do to work and then you're going to try
another decision that's not going to
work and you're going to try something
else that's not going to work you try
something else and that is going to work
a little bit
you're going to learn a little bit from
that and because you had to fight and
struggle and go through all those
difficulties to learn that little bit of
knowledge that's going to mean so much
more to you than
hearing somebody else go through that
struggle
and observing somebody else go through
that struggle so uh those were his two
pieces of advice i told you the part
that he said everybody all gonna ignore
that advice then you can come back i
ignored the advice so i went off and i
uh i was like hey i wanna be a meta
entrepreneur you know i was a small
scale entrepreneur in uh pet food i'm
gonna be a meta entrepreneur i'm going
to go to one of these you know
private equity firms i'll help run 10
businesses and like i'm going to learn
more and then i'll go to get do my own
thing and just turns out that's not true
like you know private equity is about
being the finance finance or strategy
guy but it's you're not actually running
the business you're not making the
decisions and you're not
kind of living and breathing uh being an
operator
so uh after about a year and a half of
that i said okay i'm gonna go into
industry and actually find
a job that's interesting to me in uh in
the in the internet space because it's
kind of it's booming now and you know as
a computer geek in junior high so why
don't i go and do that
uh so i looked around a bunch of things
and ended up going uh and finding
hotjobs.com now how many of you
have how many of you have heard of
hotjobs.com at this point a little
higher i need your hands a little higher
uh probably only about a fifth of the
room so at that point it was the uh
number two job board in the u.s behind
uh monster
and just to show hands for fun how many
of you ever applied for a job out of the
newspaper you saw an ad in the newspaper
and a couple of us okay great
uh it's like the secret fraternity of
people who remember newspapers right
they showed up on your
doorstep uh and so i joined i joined hot
jobs and sounded like really interesting
and kind of obvious well look
people print out their resumes and send
them in and people have jobs and they
put them on a piece of paper and that
you know gets attached to the back of
your newspaper
it seems like information technology is
probably going to make those two things
go away right and it's all going to be
done
online or through electronic means so i
joined uh hot jobs just had an amazing
uh amazing experience
uh
uh you know
because you're at a uh they're already
public when i joined them uh i ended up
kind of taking over a very com com era
was a little bit crazy i ended up having
a strange job where i ran uh corporate
development that's all of our
conversations with
other companies about partnering or
acquiring them business development
online marketing and then content and
community on the site
uh and just an amazing experience so to
get to see all these different uh parts
of the business
in a company that grew from 88 people
three months before i joined it i was
employed 222
to 700 people six months later
uh it's just this amazing uh amazing
rocket ship
and uh
eventually uh yahoo bought us and uh uh
boss for a half billion dollars and uh
yahoo did what they do with all their
acquisitions which is they managed us
horribly and made everybody leave right
uh
i mean it's actually kind of a core com
i'm on camera aren't i
sorry it's uh it's true uh if you if you
if you i mean if you look before marissa
meyer okay before marisa uh
you're good uh but it was really a core
competency they'd acquire your business
and like the top ten people would leave
within six months and so i
uh i left within uh uh six months
uh just because they're a large company
it just it didn't work and uh i wanted
to do something entrepreneurial at that
point i'm like okay i had gone to the
the big uh
the private equity firm i'd done the uh
uh kind of very interesting fast-growing
uh internet company had done a lot of
very very interesting uh different
things
why don't i go and do something you know
also in uh in online recruitment
and uh the interesting thing to me was
that at that point this is 10 years ago
kind of two areas of the market that
weren't being uh addressed where the
hourly market kind of the lowest end of
the market and the upper end of the
market people making
uh you know over 100k a year and um
to me that really seemed like kind of
the most
interesting uh interesting parts of the
business
i
ultimately uh uh
decided to do the higher end of the
higher end of the scale and the way that
came about was uh so i'm from a big
irish italian catholic family i've got
36 first cousins
can anybody beat that by the way who's
got more than 36 yes
how many
45
36
57
so i i've so
the highest number i've heard on that
one though uh was a guy at hbs at 67 and
he beat me but 57 is pretty amazing
that's awesome
uh
and uh and so a couple of my uh cousins
lived in new york there are high-end uh
uh sales people um
and you know they called me and said hey
you know
mr hot jobs where can i find like a
really great job really great sales job
you must know i was like well it's
really easy just go online and you just
kind of look all the stuff and you can
see all the jobs on there and you apply
and so she said to me well how do you do
that
it's super simple i have no idea what
you're talking about can you just do it
for me it's like you can see kind of
like the salesperson in her right she's
getting me to do her work for her uh and
so i'm like okay fine i'll go do it so i
went and got a bunch of job listings put
them into an email and sent them off to
her
that is terrific this is awesome next
week she calls back hey that's really
great can you do it again i got no
problem i got it and did all the surfing
put the links in the email send it off
to her great
calls me again the third week wow those
are great can you do that again so at
this point my expensive
business school education kicks in and i
say hey here is a customer with an unmet
need
right uh
they need she needs my cousins need
a listing of high-end jobs it's actually
a little bit difficult at that point to
actually find just even finding them is
kind of tough
uh and so i call a guy who had worked
for me at hotjobs
and i was like alex here's my idea we're
going to take all the great jobs out
there
we're going to put them into an email
newsletter and we're going to uh email
it to customers we're going to charge
them 25 bucks a month for it
and he said mark i think that's a great
idea alex i think it's a good idea it's
like mark i think it's a great idea i'm
like alex i think it's a great idea so
we went out we talked to a bunch of
software developers uh they all told us
it would be three months and thirty
thousand dollars to build a prototype
uh and you guys you guys know that
prototype is techjargon4 it worked when
i gave it to you right uh
and at the time now that seems cheap and
fast but at the time i was like you know
uh wow i i you know i don't want to wait
three months i don't want to give you
thirty thousand dollars so i went out
and bought a bunch of php and my sql web
programming books taught myself enough
web programming uh to launch the site
and through build build the site and
launch it in three weeks it was a very
very very simple site uh
but the important thing was that we were
live right and we could send emails and
we had the jobs listed on the site and
uh you know at the beginning it was all
it was all free now which who here is in
that 10 week what's the 10 week boot
camp called
tech boot camp that's
your marketing genius is behind that
name right
simple call it what it is duh right so
tech how many people in tech bootcamp
yeah great so like right now the things
that you are learning in your 10 week
program how many of you feel you know
i'll just tell you like a lot you're
going to be in a position at the end of
10 weeks that you're going to be able to
at least create a prototype of something
that you know is interesting and that
you can uh get customer reactions to so
we launched at the end of august with uh
three subscribers out of uh actually out
of a craigslist ad
and uh uh you know it was kind of off to
the races and we could learn from what
people
responded to us about the job listings
that we were
that we were sending them
and in the early days what it was was
kind of during the week we were doing
like all the business stuff like the
marketing and the let's see if we can
get free interns from nyu and how we're
going to raise money and what we're
going to do and then we actually on the
weekend we set aside the weekends too
we're going to actually collect all the
jobs that we're going to send to people
right and so it was our shifts were
friday night five to ten saturday 10 a.m
to 10 p.m and then sunday noon until
whenever he got uh and whenever he got
it done
and uh usually be some time after
midnight and so we you know it was me
and two guys that worked for me with me
at hot jobs and so uh
i don't know it's like you know eight or
nine weeks in and uh
uh the way it would work is we kind of
finished sometime sunday after midnight
and then i was the editor
uh and so i would have to go through and
edit all the jobs to make sure they're
right in the right right buckets and
then i was the coder at the at the
company so around four o'clock in the
morning i'd start coding the thing to
send out the weekly email
and then i thought it was important to
kind of say something in the weekly
email that we sent out to everybody uh
so around 7am i'd start you know writing
the email that it goes out to everybody
i don't know it's like eight or nine
weeks in and i'm just like i pulled a
couple on others that week you know and
it gets to you know it's like really
really important to me to like get it
done by 9 a.m in the morning and get
this out there so people to start their
job hunt and i just can't get it done
yeah you know nine o'clock comes and
goes and like you know
the the keys on the keyboard like this
big i can't like hit them anymore the
screen's talking back to me and
not the reason the screen talks back to
you guys in college though right and uh
and uh
i just can't get it done so it comes to
like 9 16 9 17 in the morning and ding
in my inbox
hey uh the ladders you guys didn't go
away did you where's my weekly
newsletter i needed to start my job hunt
9 18 in my inbox ding ding hey where are
you guys you're not one of those little
dot coms that went out of business i
really need you to search for my job
like that is the moment when kinda you
know the uh the clouds part and that the
ray of sunshine comes down yeah right
it's like you know the
message in the bottle washes up on the
shore that's like when you really know
that you've done something when it's
like eight or nine weeks into it and you
know it's a free product and people have
already changed
their behavior based on the thing that
you created so we we kind of knew that
we were onto something uh so at that
point it was a free product
and you got a lot of you who are
starting your companies are kind of
pre-revenue so you know how this uh this
feels we're we're doing the uh weekly
meeting at my apartment in manhattan's
east village uh and then everybody's
working from home during the week and at
that point i was a bachelor and so like
my idea of hospitality was i don't know
i still don't know what i was thinking
but everybody come over and have a plate
of salami and pringles out right and
that was
guys look what i got for you right
salami and pringles have as much as you
want
uh
i don't know what i was thinking and uh
so eventually it's like oh look
we got it if we're gonna make this thing
work we gotta you know find you know get
like an office or something
and uh so you know went around town and
found like one of those office spaces
before the weworks and the general
assemblies came along uh and you know
they they gave you a
it's great choice they give you it's
like uh so probably from me to that wall
and then like from here over to those
chairs is the size of the room
the interior room without the windows is
a thousand bucks a month and the
exterior room with like a window and
sunlight is 1500 a month and so which
one do you take when you start off
right the thousand buck a month one
right with no sunlight and uh the guy
who runs the place he's not a dummy he's
like i've seen a lot of your startups
come and go it's 2003. you're going to
be out of business before you even start
so it's six months in advance and a
month security deposit right
great
so uh you know so i go in and uh you
know it's one of those it's one of those
moments that you come to in your life
when you're uh when you're an
entrepreneur and it's it's important and
you guys all come to it uh so you know i
go in and uh sit down with them and i
write you know write out the check is
november 14 2003 uh
paid to executive office suites amount
you know seven thousand dollars and then
they make you like write it out like in
full just to remind you how stupid
you're being right seven thousand
dollars
uh
and uh
for
rent
and then you come to the line
you come to the signature line
and it's that line that separates the
past from the future
it's the line that separates the people
who talk about being an entrepreneur
from being an entrepreneur
it's a line that all of you are going to
face sooner or later in your career
where your colleagues
your classmates your friends are going
to be saying hey i've got this great job
at
google goldman sachs the government
facebook twitter someplace why don't you
come here and work with me
and you're going to have to make that
decision for yourself as to whether you
really want to be an entrepreneur
or whether you're whether you don't it's
you know it's okay if you don't want to
be an entrepreneur most you know what we
call people who don't want to be
entrepreneurs
customers
right
and it's okay
uh if there weren't for them what would
we do but uh
you come to that line and so i signed
that line i was thinking you know i say
sign my name in that line i said this is
either going to be like a good idea or
it's going to be the dumbest most
expensive hobby i've ever had
uh
so from that point we uh uh so we were
free we started charging in january of
2004 uh we
you know the free product the day before
we started charging was 300 you get 300
300 jobs a week sent to your uh inbox
the free product the day after we
started charging was you get 300 jobs a
week sent to your inbox but the paid
product was you get 1200 jobs sent and
you get them sent two weeks before
everybody else and uh you know we were
kind of is off to the races uh uh from
there for us
uh we
ended up raising uh an angel round of
about three quarters of a million and
then a series a round
10 months 8 months later of 7 million
when you're looking to raise money
particularly at that time the easiest
way to raise money is to
already have revenue coming in the door
if you can say look
actually i don't need your money to stay
in business but it can help me get there
faster we already have enough dough
coming in to you know
keep the lights on uh that's like a very
uh you know attractive uh attractive
thing so over the years at uh
uh at the at the ladder so i spent uh
what i spent
eight years as uh ceo i'm now founder
and chairman uh so still active in the
business but uh handed the
ceo reigns over to my co-founder two
years ago
i think looking back on that experience
the two most important things i would
recommend to all of you as you're
thinking about this really the two most
important things and really just about
everything else falls away in importance
is the people you work with
and your product
and the and really the customer's
relationship to your uh uh to your
product
there are a couple different uh
uh slide decks out there there's one
from uh dropbox that goes through all of
the dumb management mistakes that they
made
and just it's really every single man
everything everything they did as a
management team was wrong right except
for
the product the product really really
really made sense and their point
in their deck is
product market fit
can cover and excuse almost all sins of
management
almost all and in in this particular
this state it wasn't true 20 years ago
maybe it won't be true in 20 years but
in this particular day and age it really
is true
if you get product market fit if you get
a product that your customers say
i have to have this
just about everything else will work out
uh and so the really really important
thing for you as you're thinking through
my product or what am i building or as
in the boot camp as you uh think about
what you're building is
are people crazy about it
if they don't have it will they email
you at nine in the morning on a monday
morning
if they don't have it will their life be
worse
right if uh if split wise went away
splitwise went away uh would would you
would you write to them and say my god
where'd you guys go i need to split my
bills
yes no maybe perhaps and then
the gentleman who's using left is out
right right but if lift went away it
sounds like he might actually like write
to them and say my god and you and your
app if your rap went away would you
write to yourself
you're you're like ready to pop out of
your c whatever it is whoever's at a vc
in this room invest in this man's
business because he's like he's got some
energy
uh
so the most important thing really is is
that product market fit can solve so
many other uh so many other problems
uh
and the way that you the only way you're
gonna get to really a great a great
great great product is working with
terrific people i have had so many times
over the years either people who work
for me or people who
uh you know have their own startup
business
come to me with the
yes but explanation
yeah you know
andy is not the really the right guy for
the job
but we really need somebody right now
helen isn't quite what we were hoping
for but
it's important for us to have another
engineer
uh any time that you find yourself
saying yes but about somebody that
you're thinking of hiring or somebody
you're bringing on board i think the
most important thing to
one of my favorite quotes is warren
buffets
where he says
after some early mistakes
in business i learned
to only ever work with people that i
like
trust
i'm sorry i like trust respect and
admire
and i've never made an error after doing
that
uh and i don't know i read that like
probably six or seven years ago after
making some of those errors some of
those hiring errors
and it's really really true if you only
work with people that
you like trust respect and admire
now if you're sitting here and you
haven't how many people have never hired
anybody before how many of you have not
hired people before right so about half
half two-thirds of the room uh so this
is going to sound a little bit abstract
to you like what does that mean to hire
people i mean don't i just need to like
add people your team
so yes and no it's a little it's a
little abstract but uh
i mean doesn't it kind of make sense
like when you think about when you
perform best in life
when you think about when you're best on
a sports team when you perform best in a
study group when you perform best in a
conversation
it's when you're work it's when your
teammates or the people that you're
you're with are people that you
you feel understand you and you feel
well i i kind of get them and they get
me and i i enjoy watching what they do
in sports or music or whatever it is
that that's kind of an eternal truth and
that doesn't change just because you get
into business
so if you can take away something uh i
follow that advice hey only work with
people that you like
trust
uh respect uh and admire
uh so for
uh so for the ladders we kind of we were
took off with like a uh went off like a
rocket ship uh you know the business was
hey it's free for employers to charge uh
free for employees to post their jobs
and we charge professionals 25 bucks a
month or 150 bucks a year to get access
to kind of all the listings and over the
years the website's gotten more and more
uh detailed
uh in 2008 we uh after talking to a lot
of people we got some advice that hey
look fortune 1000 companies are never
going to take you seriously if you're a
free
resource
uh we and so we actually we went and we
charged you know uh we decided hey great
then we'll charge
corporates for access to the to the
system uh it actually ended up being a
bad decision we spent
every different which way and uh over
the next four years trying to
solve for the errors in that decision
what happens when you charge in a
two-sided network
you can charge one side for access to
the network
and you can charge the other side for
additional services or additional
information you can't charge both sides
for access to the network because what
that does is it reduces your overall
network size and kind of the activity
going on on the site
over four years we tried every every
different which way we tried uh look
there's a free three months if you sign
up there's if it's a very small amount
of usage it's free if you
tell us that you hired a lot of people
we'll reduce the reduce the price for
you
at the end of it after four years we've
just decided look that's it's just
simply not working and uh what we'll do
is we're gonna actually go all the way
back to our original model which is
it's free for employers to post jobs and
uh we're to continue to charge job
seekers and i think in the last four in
the four years that we were
had made that decision the world changed
and fortune 1000 companies kind of
changed their thinking on
free tools
so that as a result now
looking back we're probably twice as
large as we were uh in 2008 when we made
that decision
um
uh and so that's where the latter story
kind of i then handed it off to my
co-founder i had spent some time with
meg whitman who was ceo at ebay early
early on the ladders and she said look
you should really only stay at the helm
of your company eight or ten years after
that time to give somebody else a shot
at it so after eight years i handed the
reins over to my co-founder
and spent some time thinking about what
i wanted to do
and what it turned out what i wanted to
do
was
still something in
people and how they represent themselves
if you think about it the latter's is
how you represent yourself in a job
here's my background here the companies
i work for here are my skill set and
that's that's kind of interesting
over the years at the ladders we've done
a lot of work with
personality types and
how different personality types work
together and how how teamwork occurs and
how it doesn't occur how many people
have heard of the
like the myers-briggs personality test
my lord that is pretty that's amazing
that's like 80 of the room uh so we had
everybody at the ladders go through and
uh do the
myers-briggs personality test and it's
really interesting when you're in a work
environment so if you're a very
analytical person
and somebody who's very relationship
driven is uh
interpersonal driven is trying to
persuade you of something what will they
do
they'll come up with all the people who
agree with them they'll come up with all
the people who like the idea
they'll point out the importance to the
groups working on it of the idea and
they'll point out all these human
relationship
factors that go into the decision
whereas if you're very analytical
all you're hearing is there is no data
behind any of this how come you are not
sharing any data
why
are you hiding the data from me
i am now angry at you
for hiding the data from me and once you
once you've done this and you've kind of
been been through the training a little
bit you see you just see it you every
conflict at work
and at home you kind of you see like
exactly what's kind of
what's feeding into it anyway
uh and so
you know i'd uh we had done some tests
at the ladders i'm getting a little bit
deeper but just because of it it was an
employment product you know decided that
we uh we couldn't and uh
you know it's kind of amazing what uh
what where what the
internet enables uh these days so if i
tell you hey i got this new idea for a
business uh
when you have a really big problem in
your life
uh you're just committed to dui and uh
you need an attorney uh you think you
have cancer
uh
or uh
or good you know something good in your
life but uh you think maybe you're
you're pregnant what i want you to do is
i want you to come type it into my site
i'm gonna take that information about
you and i'm gonna sell it to advertisers
and i'm gonna keep all the money
how do you like my business idea
how many people would invest in that
business
right that's google
right that is what google does
right you go and you type your stuff if
if you look on google i actually and i
did a long blog post on this a dui
attorney costs you a buck 37
uh to buy the click
uh am i pregnant is i think three
dollars and 17 cents
uh
uh yeah and the other ones have there's
always some price and if you think about
it uh
i don't know how about well how about
this room if let's say you
you saw uh you decided how many people
ever had that thing happened to you
where you're like i've got some fatal
horrible disease i know it i'm gonna go
yeah
i know i've got it now it's
all over for me and did you go talk to
your friends about it first you go to
google first and type in you know
symptoms
a couple you went to google first yeah i
see some nods out there and it's kind of
interesting for thousands of years we as
people for millions of years like you
had some big problem or some big issue
you went to
the village elder you went to you know
your religious figure you maybe you went
to you know your best friend or your
sponsor what not uh
today increasingly we can't we go to
google we go to the internet first to
kind of search these things and isn't
that kind of very very
interesting that that is one of the
first places that we go
and uh so my friends over at uh okcupid
have uh have done some research on how
many people read their blog okay cupid's
blog yeah it's one of the most
just the side of the room right
this is the data driven side of the room
i don't know uh
and uh
so they got me they asked like 250 000
questions on okcupid all these questions
you can answer about five thousand high
rotation and so they did a uh uh you
know they did a correlation
uh
uh
between you know the answer these
questions and other things that they
could find out about you so uh one of
the famous blog posts he did is let's
say you want to find out about you know
somebody you're meeting for a first date
but you don't want to ask them you know
the questions directly like you don't
want to ask them about their politics uh
directly or their religion directly or
those types of things well are there
questions that correlate with those
answers
to their politics and religion that very
highly correlate that you could ask them
that wouldn't be so obvious
and it turns out that there are so uh
um
the uh so the famous one
and i've got to do this on camera so
it's uh so the famous one is if you uh
if you want to find out if uh
you're gonna get lucky on your first
date right uh
like you don't you obviously don't ask
that uh directly but uh
what question could you answer and this
blog says not me but this blog says the
question most highly correlated with
uh promiscuity on their site is do you
like the taste of beer so people who
answer yes
are twice as likely to end up being
promiscuous as as people who uh answer
no let's say you want to answer so you
want to find out about your uh first
dates politics and you want to ask
directly are you conservative or liberal
what other question could you answer ask
and the question is
do you prefer the people in your life to
be simple
or complex
now i love this question because i've
kind of shared this with audiences all
over the country in blue states and red
states
both sides think they're right
uh so uh
so if you're so if you answer i like the
people to be my life to be more complex
are you conservative or liberal what do
you think
liberal and if you say i like people
know if you are simple you conserve a
liberal you're conservative what
liberals and i'm assuming from the last
in the audience that
uh
i'm guessing
uh blue state that's changed is uh of
course you want people in your life to
be complex is that complexity and kind
of interesting and it's kind of amazing
that people do that and who wants people
boring simple people people in red
states say who wants those people who
put on airs and are always kind of
faking and posing about being something
that they're not instead of being good
simple ordinary
americans and that's what and so both
sides kind of think that they're right
uh you want if you want to find out if
uh somebody is religious or not you
don't want to ask them directly you ask
do spelling and grammar mistakes
irritate you
and if you say yes what do you think are
you religious are you
say you say yes spelling grammar
mistakes irritate me are you twice as
likely to be religious or not religious
not religious
religious people are more forgiving
right this is
i guess i guess
that's what the data say i'm just i'm
you know posing on it but uh
yeah maybe it's expelling grammar errors
like who cares it's this world right
there's something in the next it matters
a lot more
i don't know we all went to yale right
the spelling grammar sticks really
irritate us right um
but so anyway so the interesting thing
about it so first off those are fun
party tricks but uh second uh isn't that
fascinating okay i was studying poli-sci
here
at yale um
and and i've done a ton of reading and i
had never kind of like really put those
like that conservative liberal thing
together
uh before and isn't it interesting that
the vast scale of the internet allows us
to create these correlations between
things that people didn't even realize
that they were telling us
right that they they didn't know that
they were telling us uh when they
answered those uh those other questions
um
and so i thought wow that is kind of
fascinating what else can i figure out
about people
by having them or their friends answer
questions
uh
what else can i figure out about them
that they don't necessarily realize or
that they you know i think they're
having fun doing so my new business is
called nozen it's originally was kind of
a dozen people you know about you best
so no dozen shortened nose and know zen
and we're bringing personality to the
internet uh and basically what we're
doing is we're crowdsourcing personality
profiles so when you sign up and you can
all sign up go to nosin.com and uh when
you sign up we'll show you people from
your work or your school or people in
your social network and we'll ask you
questions like
uh between heather and james who's more
analytical between uh sally and susan
who's more likely to invite you out for
happy hour between uh bob and steve
who's more
uh
organized
so uh
and from all those little data points
we're able to create
a personality profile a crowd-sourced uh
a personality profile
uh for each person in the uh in the
system
um
so i had this idea two years ago and the
uh
i realized it needed to be mobile
and uh
something that people do when they kind
of do try to go out and do their second
bit uh their second kind of
entrepreneurial venture after the first
ones had some scale of success is they
try to not do everything that they did
before because it was so painful to go
through and like do the oh man i gotta
go do the uh uh be in the small little
uh uh
you know rented office space or i gotta
like code the thing up from scratch or i
gotta like you know uh hack it out with
developers a lot of people seek to avoid
that and as i've gone around talk to my
venture capital friends it turns out
that a couple of them say our highest
rate of failure among entrepreneurs is
second time entrepreneurs who try to do
something different than what they did
before
and so i said i'm going to learn from
that um
you know there's also it's a similar
thing actually music there's the uh the
sophomore out uh the sophomore slump
like the the band comes out they do a
great first album the second you know
album it's kind of like yeah
i don't know it's not that great um
i think a lot of it's because people
don't do the thing that they uh that
they did before so i knew i realized
this had to be uh had to be mobile uh
and the
danger for
anybody going from one platform to
another is
that they'll try to apply the lessons
from the prior platform to the new one
so if you were a mainframe person and
you tried to apply those lessons to the
pc era it just didn't work
i've been a desktop guy for around 30
years and i want to do something on
mobile and so i said look that's if i
just kind of go and hire a bunch of
people then try to tell them off of my
instincts what to do i'm that's never
going to work so i actually said i'm
going to go and i'm going to learn from
the ground up again
coding and actually i've never really
been a proper developer so i'd like to
do it you know one time all the way
through so i spent a year learning
objective c python uh amazon web
services nginx enough on security to be
dangerous
uh and i said i'm gonna get the
alpha version of the site out myself i'm
no help i'm gonna get the alpha version
out uh me personally so i spent over a
year building it and uh learning shipped
it last summer
uh it worked
you know it didn't crash out in the wild
then went out and raised uh two and a
quarter million uh from uh
to my vc buddies in uh new york in the
fall
uh the best way the sec the next best
way to raise venture capital when you're
kind of doing it the second time around
isn't to show up on somebody's doorstep
and say hey i need to raise a bunch of
money today can you can you help me out
it's 12 really 12 months before i was
starting i reached out and said hey
here's what i'm thinking of doing
uh over lunch or whatever hey here's
what i'm doing would you be interested
at the time that i decided to kind of
raise money would you be interested in
participating maybe oh maybe yes okay
great
nine months before you know i'm actually
going to raise money hey i'm still
working on that thing just let you know
i'm still cranking away i think i'm
gonna have the alpha out you know pretty
soon six months ahead of time hey i got
the alpha learned some interesting stuff
and not raising money now but
next time or next next time i talk to
you i probably am going to be three
months before hey uh things are going
great i'm really
pretty fired up when i come back from uh
summer vacation labor day i'm gonna be
raising money in three months when i
talk to you so i ended up coming back uh
last september and it was really it was
ten days end to end uh to raise money
because i kind of told people all the
way along hey here's here's what we're
doing
uh interesting you know tons of
interesting stuff compared this time to
last time uh you know the tool sets out
there are completely amazing it's amazon
web services in itself is uh totally
amazing uh one of the things that when i
was starting uh this one i needed a
little bit of help after i got past the
alpha on uh
uh just saying some python back-end
stuff and some uh
things on the iphone and ended up hiring
people just part-time just 10 hours a
week off of off of odesk have you guys
heard of odesk right so it's kind of
like the global freelance market and
amazingly talented people on there and
it ended up turning in from five hours
to ten hours to uh actually two of the
guys now full-time on my uh on my staff
uh although they're based in the ukraine
and china i've never met them
personally
they're
you know they're more comfortable
chatting than in spoken or video video
english just because it's a second
language so chatting is a lot more
comfortable for them uh you know and
it's now it's very easy to have a global
workforce
um
in a way that just wasn't possible a few
years ago managing remotely is also
pretty pretty interesting
how many people in the room have managed
a remote team
before no maybe not so uh so yeah yeah
uh so uh when you're managing like a
team that's hey five people let's get
together hey 10 people let's i'm going
to tell you what we're doing let's do it
we've got it up on the board all right
let's all go that's one way to manage
managing a team remotely that doesn't
come in every day it's not not
physically there uh the concept of face
time or office time just doesn't exist
it's really it's for me it's been a very
interesting intellectual challenge uh
and actually turned out to be uh to be
great
so uh i spent the last uh eight months
since raisin uh doe building really the
proper release release version uh which
uh we submitted to the app store this
uh actually last week we'll be coming
out next week and you can sign up for it
at nozin.com i've learned my lessons
from this gentleman over here about
promoting your app
uh
and um
uh we'll see how things go when we get
it out into the wild and that's really
when the hard work will begin and we'll
start learning from uh from customers
so uh with that
uh why don't i turn it over to alana
first of all thank you for your time in
this semi hot room and then when i uh
open it to questions any and all
questions from you guys
45 minutes talk time without looking at
the watch i'm patting myself on the back
all right great yes sir
uh so in the long run it'll be off of a
personality api
so uh
if you think about it so um
humans uh
one way of thinking about humans are wet
machines compared to dry machines like
computers or planes or cars
and we behave
relatively consistently but not entirely
consistently
the patterns to our behavior are called
personality so somebody's very
analytical will have certain behaviors
that they go through somebody's very
organized certain behaviors they go
through
uh wouldn't it be interesting and useful
to understand something about those
patterns in aggregate
so yeah and so those will be useful for
uh hr
so your global company has ten thousand
teams a thousand are top performers a
thousand are bottom performers
what about the makeup of those teams can
you learn from personality
uh
for personal development for marketing
if uh you know i'm a very i'm an
analytically driven person if somebody
tries to market to me with testimonials
of like other people who bought it like
i just don't like i don't care i don't
read that right it doesn't i want to see
the specifications i want to see the
data somebody who's very
relationship driven actually says you
guys who think you think specifications
are the way to go you don't actually
know what's going to make you happy you
should listen to what people say and go
with testimonials
um
technology like right now when
so every new every time you open up a
new product uh so you open up a new
version of your bank's website
or a new version of xcode or new version
of gmail
today technology treats all of us on
this side of the screen like we're
exactly the same at the start
but we're not like we know that we're
not well wouldn't it be interesting if
there's a personality api that could say
well this is a very organized person
show them the three-page tutorial this
is a very spontaneous person who's not
structured just show them the big
buttons and tell them where to get help
later
uh
that's me right i won't read a tutorial
but like i just want to know the big
buttons and then if i really need your
thing later i'll go read your
stuff later in the help section uh
recruiting i just
anything where
understanding the uh
um
tendencies of human beings would be
important
will be useful
because your characterization of google
is like interesting
so yeah it's like i'm drinking water
right
i should have one in my hand okay but uh
yeah yeah uh the reason you do is
because so
uh social apps uh that try to create a
new human behavior fail
uh social apps that try to augment
existing human behaviors have a shot
uh
so
you know if you like if you go through
any company if you go through uh
uh
you know any dining hall here and you're
like listen to what people are talking
about
hey what you know they're talking about
their friends who's up who's down who's
like this what's he like what do you
think of him hey what's that guy guys
kind of a pain in the ass what's up with
that you know
isn't she awesome that's what people
talk about all day uh
let's give them a way to do let's give
them an app that makes that even more
fun right so
uh
so one of the things that we've done in
the beta is every uh every few days we
spit out an email
that either says
someone from
yale rated you more assertive than cindy
with a big picture of cindy there
okay now i knew that was going to be an
engaging email but i didn't realize that
people would see it as validation
right and so people take these emails
and they forward them to cindy to their
colleagues they're like
told you so
uh and then the other one is uh top 11
oh yeah top 11 or top 15
most
friendly people in new york city or most
analytical people in chicago and that
one's all so
like we're inch we're you know we're
we're
we're storytelling apes right we tell
stories and the stories that we tell uh
usually revolve around other other
people right and what they did and what
they didn't do and
i mean all like if you want to think
about like personality is world
literature it's world cinema i mean
that's all it is it's like these two
different
if you want to like really
get it down to like the basics of
structure it's you know a few different
people with like different personality
types
interacted in a surprising manner right
and uh
and so those stories are what people are
really interested in so we're gonna
make those interesting and more fun for
people
please download
so in my particular case
uh in private equity or consulting your
banking in general your your
the times that you interact with clients
tend to be uh so structured in set piece
that it's uh like nobody's really got
their true face on right they got their
mask on uh so it's
it's difficult how many how many times
are there meetings are you in consulting
i see some other heads in the room
nodding they're attacking consulting how
many times is it that like you have the
meeting here
and then everybody goes out and like can
you believe what he said i can't believe
what that guy said he said terrible i
don't agree with anything like the
meeting the real meeting happens outside
of the room um
so i like my person so i learned a ton
uh but uh it wasn't it helped me learn
what i mean it helped me on my path
right it helped me discover what wasn't
right uh for me and
i think uh was it caroline in the front
row here you said that your first year
you took a all these different courses
and helped you learn what majors not to
be right and that's an important thing
in life like we're learning what what
not to do
one of the and one of the things for uh
you know for people in college uh your
whole life has been about opening doors
hey
music wow hey the kinks i can't believe
that's an amazing thing hey i never
realized i liked highlight right you
know it's all about opening doors
right
soccer this is amazing world cup uh
after college it gets to closing doors
and when you're sitting in college you
sit in this classroom you're kind of
sitting here thinking my god that sounds
awful i'm gonna close doors i'm gonna
it's kind of like dying isn't it
right it's just like i'm closing doors
in preparation for being dead
but it's not right and what you learn is
that uh learning what you enjoy
and learning what like you know actually
like you can contribute to what you get
back in which you can get deeper in
uh is actually kind of an enjoyable
process and so learning about the things
that the doors to close
uh is important so for me like learning
that 18 months to close that door on
private equity was you know it was good
for me even though it turned out that
that
industry isn't the right one for me